it is a strange time to try and be funny
but trying to be funny is SNL's whole
thing so we thought what the heck let's
give it a shot but why me is host well
for one I have been the celebrity canary
in the coalmine for the coronavirus
that's Tom Hanks introducing the new
format of Saturday Night Live at home
from his kitchen
the Oscar winner opened the show with a
heartfelt monologue making light of the
elephant in the room
and ever since being diagnosed I have
been more like America's dad than ever
before since no one wants to be around
me very long and I make people
uncomfortable all jokes aside Tom and
his wife Rita Wilson were two of the
first celebrities to reveal they
contracted kovat 19 back in March the
two spent a few days at the hospital
before quarantine at a home in Australia
now the folks in Australia are fantastic
in every way but they use celcius
instead of Fahrenheit when they take
your temperature so way come in and they
say yeah 36 which seemed very bad to me
but it turns out 36 is fine 38 is bad so
basically it's how Hollywood treats
female actors once Rita and Tom
recovered they made their way back to
their home in Los Angeles my wife had to
help me put it on because I forgot how
buttons work but it turns out there's
these little discs and they slide into
these slots amazing Tom introduced
viewers to SNL's new format which was
filmed by the SNL cast who are all
currently quarantined in their homes now
is it gonna look a little different than
what you're used to yes will it be weird
to see sketches without big sets and
costumes sure but will it make you laugh
it's SNL you know there'll be some good
stuff maybe one or two stinkers you know
the drill
Tom ended his monologue on a serious
note with a message to America stay safe
we are in this for the duration and we
will get through this together we are
going to thank our hospital workers our
first responders and all the helpers the
supermarket stalkers the people who
deliver our
food the people who are making takeout
for us
the men and women who are keeping this
country going at the time we need them
more than ever before so we're gonna
take care of them and we're gonna take
care of each other so let's try to now
just enjoy the show when it comes to the
show
one of the standout moments was Alec
Baldwin busting out his recurring
impression of President Donald Trump
[Music]
we're happy to report problem in America
is now number one of the world when I
was president
hashtag America number one hashtag not
important why what exactly is your
advice because it seems to change every
24 hours
that's a nasty question very nasty the
writers also threw in a reference to the
Netflix mega hit Tiger king but in times
like this we need to come together as
one nation because no matter our
differences all Americans can agree on
one thing
Carole Baskins definitely fed her
husband to those Tigers 2020 find out
this way whatever feeling pants is gonna
be pretty into go exotic
[Music]